insert your own because I'm Batman joke
here so new word on what is going on
with the DC EU and the project of the
Batman specifically the word is now that
director Matt Reeves is tossing out the
existing script that had been worked on
by Ben Affleck and Geoff Johns that's
not a huge surprise that was indicated
that he was going to be doing some
serious rework on it anyway so taking
the step to actually check it and start
over is not a huge step beyond them but
I still want to take the opportunity to
talk about it and why I think it's a
good thing in fact a very good thing now
before I get into it I do want to
clarify I don't think that it's a good
thing because of any sort of assumption
of quality or a lack of quality in the
original script either in the story or
the nitty gritty of the actual finished
product itself because I haven't read
the thing I mean it could have been
great for all I know or it could have
been junk I mean there's a heck of a lot
of speculation and rumor out there
actual hard details about it are few and
far between and some of them are
contradictory so exactly what was in the
original script no idea it could have
been great doesn't matter because even
if it was great I still think this is a
good thing because what it indicates is
it indicates a switch of mindset from
Warner Brothers in their production of
these movies and I think it is the first
well maybe not the first but certainly
the latest in solid indications that
they are adjusting their overall
approach to these things and it shows
that they understand that Batman they
need to get right because to quote Will
Arnett as Lego Batman DC the house that
Batman built because maybe not
necessarily in the comics themselves you
can argue between him and Superman but
certainly in all adaptation media yeah
Batman is king and I mean not only King
/ DC king of superheroes king of all of
them forget Marvel forget anybody else
Batman is the top so if they get this
wrong and they blow it they are in big
in trouble and I think this move shows
that Warner Brothers has an appreciation
of that and the reason I feel that is
because it shows that they weren't just
bringing in Matt Reeves
to just plug him in as the director for
the existing script they already had
because if that was all they were going
to do you know you don't hire Matt
Reeves for that you hire Brett Ratner
for that or maybe Ron Howard but they're
showing that they brought him in and I'm
sure he was showing the existing script
and I'm sure Warner Brothers probably
would have preferred that he go this is
great I'll choose this because it could
have gotten them in production sooner
but they are allowing him to come in
with his own planning his own intention
and again I'm not making any
presumptions that he looked at the
script and thought it was crap but at
the very least the official looked at
the script and gone for what I want to
do with Batman this story the script
doesn't get me there let me do my own
thing and still there is no start of
production date and there's no release
date for this film both of these in this
situation given the state of the DC EU
and sort of how things appear to be
getting reconfigured somewhat right now
this is all good stuff because I think
the biggest mistake that Warner Brothers
could have made was to get married or
any director and just go here here's the
script shoot it or even if they were to
say hey you can do your own story but
we're starting on this date whether you
have finished the story or not which is
kind of basically what they did David
Ayer and Suicide Squad either one of
those would have been a huge mistake
because it would have gotten into a rush
production half-baked script and they
would have been banking on just the name
of Batman alone to sell the movie
regardless of how well the story
actually worked I think they have woken
up to the fact that and again you know
you may like Batman V Superman you may
like Suicide Squad you may have liked
the DCE you of this one but again you
cannot argue with the fact that it is
very divisive and I think they are wise
to the fact that Ben Affleck is one of
the few pieces of goodwill they had
pretty much across the board coming out
Batman V Superman because even people
who were critical of the film were by
and large not critical of his
performance they may have been critical
of some of the details of the
characterization
and the writing around Batman but not of
his performance so they need to cuddle
that goodwill that they've got attached
to Ben Affleck and be sure that they
don't blow it on a half-baked on a
half-baked idea or a script that isn't
ready or a script that is being worked
on by a director who would rather be
doing something else they are they're
slowed down they're taking the necessary
time so that a director who is and has a
very good track record at this point has
a lot of time to work this material into
something that he is going to be proud
of and that hopefully they can be proud
of because I think they are looking at
what happened with Wonder Woman and they
are sort of backing up and slowing down
and going okay maybe we just need to be
sure that we are on the right page with
these people and then let them do this
thing how they're going to do this thing
arguably they may have done that with
Snyder I think seems like increasingly
as time goes on there may have been more
tinkering with even Snyder's visions of
things that would Batman be Superman and
whatnot by Warner Brothers but certainly
outside of him when you look at
something like Suicide Squad tinkered
with - heck I mean that was that was
kind of a disaster in terms of the
handling of the post-production and I
think they're going I think they're
rising up and going look we need to get
someone that we can just trust to do the
work and let them do it which is what
they did with Christopher Nolan with his
Batman trilogy they basically sent him
up gave him the resources and let him do
his things and it looks like they're
you're going to be doing that with Matt
Reeves and I think that is a good thing
now will it automatically result in a
good movie
no of course not Mallory's could still
have a concept that maybe doesn't work
it may turn out ultimately that he
doesn't get Batman as a character even
if he thinks he does there are a ton of
things that can still go wrong but by
slowing down by taking the time by not
being rigid - it must be ready by X
release date which they've done in the
past and certainly a studio like Fox is
notorious for by not doing those things
it gives us the breathing room to give
it the best possible chance to be good
or even great now there's still a number
of things
happening between now and whenever this
happens because yet we have no release
date we have no idea when it's going to
happen there's no way this comes on in
2018 2019 maybe maybe it depends on how
quickly marries can crank out a script
that he feels comfortable with and that
studio is willing to sign off on but
we've got Justice League and my stance
on Justice League right now has not
changed
I still don't plan to see it now I am
more open to the possibility of being
turned around on that then I have been
in the past so if I see a nutri because
you know it wasn't just dis like a
Batman V Superman that first trailer
that came out almost nothing about that
excited me but if I can get a new
trailer that gives me something that I I
can latch on to I am more open to the
possibility that maybe I can go into the
cell now this is not really because of
Joss Whedon's involvement because Whedon
has said that it's not his intention to
go in and change the movie it's not like
Ron Howard going in to work on Han Solo
where he's being where he's being put in
to make a different movie than the
previous directors have been making Jo
Serena said it is my intention to go in
here and finish the film that Zack
Snyder had intended to do now if he's
looking at what Zack Snyder put together
and felt that there were you know
nothing both logistical flaws to it he
may very well fix them and there's
reshoots there been reshoots and I'm
sure all that will happen but he's not
going into we denies the thing or at
least that's he that's not what he's
been hired to do and that by his own
admission is not really what he appears
to be doing and you know Zack Snyder's
vision for this universe isn't one that
I've enjoyed it just isn't but you know
we'll see what happens I I still don't
have a lot of hope for Justice League
but I'm more open to the possibility now
we'll see what happens but if I look
past it and I look further down the line
I look to how Warner Brothers is now
handling things and the fact that they
haven't rammed down you know and locked
in you know things for cyborg or Green
Lantern Corps
even though
they've announced these things that
they're working on the the fact that
they haven't locked down these dates
like and this one will come out this
year and this year and this year or if
they have it's been really vague I'm
still waiting for them to move the flash
movie they need to own enough to the
fact that that's not going to happen for
when they say it is but they seem to
have realized that part of in their
attempts to catch up to marvel and I
don't necessarily mean in terms of the
types of story I understand that they
were doing different films but I mean
timewise they've been trying to catch up
tomorrow I mean that's why they left
right to their team up movie as only
their second film even they even though
they hadn't established Batman as his
own entity up to that point they were
trying to catch up to Marvel and I think
they're realizing that rushing
everything is not doing them any favors
so and again this is separate from
whether or not you feel I or you or
anyone feels that Warner Brothers vision
for this universe is or a good thing or
not the pace of which they've been
trying to crank it out was getting us
stuff like Suicide Squad which again if
you liked it fine but that was a mess
that production was a mess and I don't
see how anyone who knows what went on
with that thing can argue otherwise so
they seem to be reassessing and going
Wittman if we're really going to bank a
long-term financial stability of our
company on projects like these maybe we
need to put quality of the product
slightly higher on the priority list
over cranking out to a year so these
things indicate a change in mentality a
change in philosophy a change in
approach from Warner Brothers towards
the Batman and hopefully by extension
towards the D CEO as a whole and that
gives me some hope I'm not suddenly
going blue everything's right now but I
do have some hope that they can turn
this around and turn it into a franchise
that I would actually like to go to the
movies to see again they got me with
Wonder Woman that was a good start so
we'll we'll see what happens but I have
some hope and I think the last couple
movies I've made about the DCE you have
had a more cautiously hopeful tone to
them and that's nice
you know as much as I ranted and raved
against DC the DC movies Warner Brothers
the DC EU I don't like hating these
things I want to like them and I have
some more hope that I will be able to
again consistently so that's going to be
it for me and my thoughts on the news
that the Batman existing script got just
what are your thoughts on all this
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it don't
forget to Like subscribe check me out on
Twitter a council of geeks give a listen
to Council of geeks podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher I'm also one half of
the punch like a girl podcast also
available on iTunes and stitcher and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]